up a Texas Family claims they're being
terrorized by a 300 lb black and white
spotted pig the deranged Beast foaming
at the mouth as it attacks family
members and breaks into their home my
daughter got hurt out here and then he
Barrel through my mom wrestled with him
at the doorway to try to prevent him
from coming in he barreled on through
got a hold of my dad my mom tried to lay
on top of him to Crunch him down to the
cops got here to get him and he
overpowered her and got on top of her
and he had her flatten an accordion an
accordion uh Jesse what are your
thoughts about this this terrorizing I'm
hungry I feel bad for her I feel bad for
the
pig look I'm a pig owner you know I had
P that's I was going to let you you were
reved up here I want you to calm down
how do you here's the thing oh there I
am that's the have you ever been
terrorized by a pig well I had two Homer
and Wilbur okay I read the kids Scarlet
web they said can we have Wilbur I said
we got two here's the thing is it we
Charlotte's Charlotte's Web
rightl it was a combination okay yeah
that's true anyway here's the thing when
one of them got a little crazy you have
to spay them you have to spay them if
you don't spay them they get crazy and
they come after you but how can it how
can a pig come into your house close the
door Shannon you seem animated about
this I just I don't but I feel bad about
laughing about it cuz this was obviously
traumatic for these people but when she
says my mom tried to Crunch down on him
tra an accordion it was traumatic for
everyone I want to know who owns this
pig though the neighbor neighb so you
got to say to the neighbor I'm going to
make some bacon if we don't get this
under control like you just got to lay
down the law you got
R in there she take care of the pig is
someone who likes barbecue ribs will you
have you have any thoughts on this yeah
I think
what's I'm not going to make a view
joke no I'm not that's what it's amazing
it's amazing maybe maybe the pig M
thought thought it was a sty thought the
place was a sty maybe she should have
cleaned it up a little I like the view
joke better there was no view joke hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else